because the new Earth is here and it is
now and we are the Warriors we are a
distributed team of new Earth
Warriors that are equals in how we
radiate sunlight onto Earth God is here
God has never left God has always been
here and you are playing hide and seek
and you are
pretending to be amused by your little
distractions and games of programs and
scripts that are complete and
nonsense and making you suffer and feel
unfulfilled and then finally one day you
turn just like the parable of the
prodigal son you finally turn and you
finally find the Portal that was never
missing that was always there and all
you have to surrender is everything all
you have to surrender is everything you
have to to surrender
everything only innocence can be let in
you have to surrender
Everything full crucifixion full
crucifixion and full
rebirth into
only new Earth only healing the entire
Collective only the collective is my
body the collective is my body the
collective is my body
and I will die for this Collective to be
completely healed transformed expanded
Into Love Light Unity Bliss peace
creativity Harmony abundance Prosperity
basic needs free energy I will die for
that I will die for that that is the
constitution of a crucified and
rebirthed Christ of God in flesh that is
God in flesh and you better believe it